ah hey you please stop bothering like  him sorry  Arthur I have some bad news for you this  is the last time we'll be meeting you  don't listen dear you just ask the same  questions every week how's your job are  you having any negative thoughts all I  have my negative thoughts  and finally in a world where everyone  thinks they could do my job  check out this guy when I was a little  boy and told people I was gonna be a  comedian everyone laughed at me well no  one's laughing now you can say that  again  [Music]  scoffs ball isn't it  [Music]  for my whole life  if I even really existed  but I do  people are starting to notice  I think this is funny  joke to you  very one small thing  yeah when you bring me out can you  introduce me as Joker  [Music]  send in the clown  [Music]  you